I know you're going to be blown away by
this but we're going to have to talk
about free speech today it would be nice
if a week would pass when there wasn't
some sort of threat to freedom of speech
but it seems that almost every day
there's a new outrage on the horizon
aimed at chipping away our right to free
expression there are three specific
happenings right now that I want to
focus on in no particular order first
there's the ongoing saga of Brett
Weinstein at Evergreen University in
Washington in case you missed our live
stream with Brett last week he's being
attacked by being called a racist and a
bigot for opposing a day in which white
students wouldn't be welcome on campus
Brett claimed that the revised day of
absence on campus based on racial
segregation was not just racist and
bigoted but was the complete reverse of
what the day was supposed to stand for
Brett has been a progressive and afar
lefty his whole life but even he is not
immune to the toxic ideology of leftism
which rates victimhood as virtue and
will swallow anyone who dares deviate
from its authoritarian rule the campus
was closed for a couple days due to
threats of violence and even now Brett
is getting no backing from the
administration which appears to be
bending to the demands of the crazed mob
even worse mainstream media is basically
all but ignoring this story because it's
so shatters the regressive ideology
mainstream left-leaning
outlets don't want to touch this story
because they don't want to be tarred the
same way Brett has been thus almost all
the coverage of the Evergreen story has
been from right-leaning websites Brett
isms three live interviews that I know
of one right here one on Joe Rogan's
podcast and one with Tucker Carlson on
Fox News he hasn't been invited on CNN
or MSNBC or NPR and none of those
outlets have even written a piece on the
story when you hear the trust in
mainstream media is at an all-time low
it's reasons like ignoring hugely
relevant stories that go against their
narrative that are part of the reason
the next story of the last few days
is was the outrage over Kathy Griffin's
isis-inspired photos holding up
president Trump's decapitated bloody
head first off on the free speech front
I fully support Kathy's right to take
these pictures and make art as she sees
fit I don't think that these photos are
a direct call to violence which would be
a crime and the pictures should be seen
through the lens that she's a comedian
and a provocateur regardless of whether
you think the images are in poor taste
or just outright awful so while it is a
hundred percent in her right to make the
images it's also a hundred percent in
CNN's right as her employer to fire her
if they see fit now interestingly in
this case it was the right calling for
CNN to fire Griffin and it was a less
that was defending her although they
were doing it a bit less than usual
while this is a flip on the script of
the last few years it's important to
remember it seems people only hold their
values when it's easy to do so just
imagine if it had been a conservative
comedian like Tim Allen holding up a
severed head of President Obama the left
would have been demanding his show be
canceled and the right would have been
defending him ironically Tim Allen's
highly rated show was canceled a couple
weeks ago and many people think that it
is at least partially because he's been
an outspoken conservative in Hollywood
the final story I want to touch on is
the outrage over Bill Maher using the
n-word on real time last Friday I can't
even repeat what Bill Maher said because
even just by quoting him I'll end up in
hot water which shows you just how
insane the language police have got
basically he made a joke using the
n-word and all hell broke loose to be
clear if you didn't use the N word to
describe anyone in particular or take a
racist position it was a line that I
suspect was prepackaged to elicit a
reaction from the crowd it not only did
elicit a reaction from the live studio
audience but also the bigoted ear
Brigade which immediately began calling
for his firing from HBO I even saw
comedians that I know calling for him to
be fired over a joke this is Bill Maher
who many of you who lean right
absolutely hate and now the left is
doing your job of trying to destroy him
sadly the left has been come
for Bill for a long time mainly because
he isn't afraid of talking about radical
Islam which has set him apart from most
on the Left I know a little thing about
that myself
HBO took the joke out of repeats of the
program and so far has withstood calls
to fire him and Maher even apologized
something he's chastised others for
doing in the past senator Al Franken
canceled an appearance on real time for
this week despite being a friend of Bill
and of the show for many years I've
invited senator Franken on the show to
discuss but I'm not going to hold my
breath so there you have it a professor
bullied off campus by threats of
violence for fighting against racism a
comedian fired for a tasteless gag and
another comic under the threat of firing
for a joke
none of these are threats to the First
Amendment which of course as you know is
the government coming for your speech
but they all add up to the chill factor
around freedom of expression that I've
been talking about for quite some time
if you are a professor would you be
willing to explore a controversial idea
with students after what's happened to
Brett if you were an artist would you be
willing to paint a controversial
painting after what's happened to Kathy
and if you were a comic would you be
willing to tell an offensive joke after
what's happening to Bill if you answered
no to any of those then you must
acknowledge that the threat to free
expression is real don't like Brett
don't take his class think Kathy is
crass watch something else on new years
don't think bill is funny change the
channel but whatever you do keep
watching the Rubin report because we've
got Jason Whitlock from Fox Sports one
on the show this week he was in his own
outrage Appaloosa
last week with the course calls for him
to be fired - but I'll save that for our
chat
[Music]
you